now Russia and Ukraine have accused each
other of carrying out attacks on New
Year's Day killing at least five people
Ukrainian rocket shelling in the Russian
held eastern city of detet killed four
people Russia says the attack was the
was launched from several areas and
Ukraine says Russian drones targeted a
residential area in the Odessa region
killing one
person this attack took place while we
were celebrating our Ukrainian New Year
who is even thinking of doing such
things what an animal can do such things
knowing well that people sat down to
celebrate Asad beg has this update from
the capital
ke as the New Year came into effect the
Ukrainian authorities said that they
were defending against a Russian drone
attack now the Ukrainian Air Force says
that the Russians launched a record
number of drones uh and they say that
they intercepted 87 of those 90 drones
the attack came in waves and in four
different directions now some of those
drones that weren't intercepted were
over the southern Port City of adessa
where Reports say one person were killed
and others were injured we also
understand that there was damage to
residential buildings resulting in fires
now the ukrainians say the Western city
of Lviv the Central City of denpro and
the southern city of MV were all
targeted by Russian drones now this has
been a busy few days uh for the
ukrainians defending Uh Russian aerial
assaults the ukrainians themselves have
launched drones at Russian Target but it
does come uh after the Friday the 29th
of December attack the widescale Russian
attack targeting cities across Ukraine
now as a result of the casualties
suffered as a result of that attack the
mayor of ke Vitali Klitschko has
declared the 1 of January a day of
morning here in the capital Assad bag Al
jazer ke